Серган Зецмен почав фотографувати 15 років тому,
коли вперше потрапив на курси до так званого Народного університету,
німецькою - Volkshochschule.
Нині він сам навчає відвідувачів курсів,
які вперше взяли в руки професійний фотоапарат.
Ми не просто сидимо в класі.
Все, чого ми навчаємо в теорії, потім закріплюємо на практиці.
Незалежно від того, чи це курси для початківців, чи складнішого рівня,
все, що учні тут вивчили,
ми тренуємо за межами класної кімнати на практиці.
Наразі ми знайомимось  з технікою і  необхідними
налаштуваннями камери. Існує також курс,
на якому навчають, як обрати мотив,
композиція кадру там у фокусі.
На нього можна піти для поглиблення знань. Я над цим ще поміркую.
Кожен Народний університет узгоджує з місцевою владою,
що запропонувати містянам.
Втім, і потенційні відвідувачі курсів можуть впливати на програму.
За наявності бажаючих, Народний університет
може підготувати спеціальний курс.
Саме так у Бонні з’явилися курси
із вивчення корейської мови і суахілі. Нині тут викладають
25 сучасних мов, а також латину та давньогрецьку.
Є і незвичні курси, наприклад,
із догляду за собакою.
Або можливість з’їздити у передмістя на реконструкцію історичної битви.
У нас дуже широкий спектр курсів.
Втім, не після кожного з них ми видаємо
дипломи чи сертифікати. Можна сказати,
що в більшості Народних університетів дипломи та сертифікати - це не найважливіше.
Значення має спільне навчання практично в усіх галузях.
Курси у Народному університеті - це, зокрема, і можливість
перекваліфікуватися чи покращити свої кар'єрні шанси.
Народні університети приваблюють не лише різноманіттям,
але й вартістю курсів.
Відвідувачі платять лише третину ринкової ціни,
решту покриває комуна і земля.
Для хобі дуже зручно, коли курси знаходяться в центрі Бонна.
І тут не так дорого. Викладачі завжди хороші.
Більшість викладачів Народних університетів Німеччини
працюють позаштатно і неповний робочий день.
Щоб викладати тут улюблену справу,
не обов'язково мати спеціальну освіту.
Якщо людина вміє добре готувати, вона не повинна
вона не повинна обов'язково бути кухарем, - але має довести,
що справді вміє добре готувати.
Народні університети місцева влада в Німеччині
почала створювати ще 100 років тому,
коли стало зрозуміло: освіта має бути
доступнішою для усіх вікових груп.
Нині таких центрів у Німеччині вже близько тисячі.
Наприклад, в 2016 році
їх відвідали понад 6,5 мільйонів людей.
Найпопулярніші курси - про здоров'я та мовні.
Народні університети почали розширювати свою діяльність
за кордон. Зокрема, втілюють проекти
із розвитку навчання для дорослих в Україні.